the United States is the greatest
country in the world what do you
apologize people for how do you believe
we're inferior to other countries or
what country do you believe is better
than the United States I feel I feel
like Great Britain and and France and
Canada I feel like those countries are
making us I mean are taking the high
road and I feel like everything I
believed in is slipping away from me
when I first fell apart it's the night
when I realized about eight o'clock that
evening that Trump was going to win
you're a veteran
um did you serve to protect freedom of
speech I did
so what about the fact that those
countries don't have freedom of speech
only the United States does you
suggested these other countries it
doesn't seem like you were totally aware
that they don't have freedom of speech I
wasn't but does that change your opinion
no you'd want to live in a you think a
country with no freedom of speech is
superiority to the United States see
that would be where just where we
disagree I think they're inferior no
freedom of speech well thank you for
taking they wanna you wanna hug you want
to hug